i want to start with a video that went
viral
over the weekend
it's not a new video it's actually a few
weeks old but it got
put on some new sites it was shared on
twitter it was shared on reddit so it
kind of got revitalized and i actually
went to go to the video itself on tiktok
yesterday and it seemed to not be
accessible but of course everyone pulled
it screenshot it embedded it so i don't
know if the nurse doesn't want it there
anymore but too bad it's already out
there anyway it was a controversial
video and it's essentially of a nurse
who has been facing backlash she
apparently according to her had a
patient that died
and she filmed
in hospital a little reaction to that i
want to show it to you and then we're
going to talk about why this video in my
opinion is a big problem and a sign of
the times that's not good let's take a
look
[Music]
okay now if you follow the video you can
see there's text on and essentially the
text says that she lost a patient
and she's going through the motions of
that experience so i have to ask first
and foremost what's wrong with the video
a lot of things
i'm going to assume that she's telling
us the truth that she did in fact lose a
patient because it would be so beyond
horrific to fake that just for a video
so let's just give her the benefit of
the doubt i like to do that and let's
say she did lose a patient if that
happened to her
why the video
you lose a patient in the hospital
you're a nurse does this seem like a
realistic display oh excuse me i just
lost a patient would you mind just
filming this for me i want to post the
video on tick tock of my reaction
that's why she's getting heat because we
live in an age now where people are
starting to realize that we are in decay
i don't use that word lightly because of
what's happening with our relationship
to social media if she legitimately went
through the motions of sadness of grief
which i'm sure nurses doctors out there
you do lose patience sometimes you do go
through traumatic events i'm sure it can
be
really really difficult to bear that
trauma but i'm guessing you also don't
rush to make a tick-tock video about it
so it looked like acting in fact my
friend clifton duncan wrote something to
be effective he hosts a podcast as well
i've been on his podcast really cool guy
uh an actor he wrote leave the acting to
the actors and it's sad because if she
did really have a moment she lost people
by doing that to it
so this got me thinking
why do we need to showcase everything on
social media why do we need to be this
type of people now where we need to look
and seek approval we need your
commentary we need you to see how we're
feeling we need you to be in that moment
with us
why do we seek that out and what is
wrong with the society that does that
all the time and it got me thinking
about
i told you guys that i had written a
book called
do not disturb a few years ago and i
remember i i had an addiction to
technology i shared that with you as
well i remember a day i was on the
brooklyn promenade
gorgeous sunset like one of those
sunsets you see that like you're like
that can't be real and i sat with my
phone and i was trying to get a picture
of it so i was looking at it through the
phone and adding a filter in and hashtag
no filter and coming up with all this
stuff
and what i ultimately
came to experience that day is i didn't
see the sunset
i missed the whole moment the only
sunset i actually saw was through the
lens of my camera because i was so busy
trying to tell you that i was having a
moment that i didn't have one
i didn't have one i missed the whole
thing by the time i was done with the
camera the sunset was done
so i'm guilty of it i am that person i
recovered from all that stuff and i
manage social media very very
differently now
but i recovered from that
because i had to because the world that
i was living in was bad and the world
that this woman is living in is bad too
this is not good
so i invite you
to look at what's happening to people in
2022
to look at what's happening to you i'm
sure you have been someone who's gone
down that path every now and then right
you're like oh let me take a
contemplative picture of myself sitting
on a patio enjoying vacation and
someone's behind that and you're like
and they run over and then you're like
could you take another one that one
doesn't i feel like i look weird and
they run back oh but you know what that
one my foot looks funny
it's all fake right
it's all fake we know it's fake
it's all fake and what's happening as a
result of this need to be liked and need
to be
everything has to be public and
everything
we're missing out on the actual moments
we're missing out on life and we're
missing out on peace because any little
amount of peace you could have had in
that moment
is gone by you trying to capture it and
display it to the world all the time
because you want some kind of acceptance
or a like or you want other people to
feel what you're feeling
it's bad
so i looked at this and it just it
rubbed me the wrong way
and it just it reminded me of a need to
just say put the apps down
if you're having an experience have it
if you're going through something go
through it
you don't need to tell everyone about it
24 hours a day you don't need them to
feel what you're feeling 24 hours a day
and you don't need to make it into a
social media meme that goes viral this
one didn't work out so well for her
because whatever authenticity existed
for her in that moment was lost by her
need to showcase it to all of us
it just looked fake
so learn from it and it's easy to
criticize it's easy for us to sit here
and criticize every single one of us the
reason i'm pointing this out every
single one of us has done this maybe not
in a hospital maybe not after losing a
patient maybe we're not a nurse we all
do it you know who doesn't do it the
older generations who look at us like
we're crazy and are like can't you just
look at the sunset
can't you just enjoy this moment if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]